my guest this week is a lawyer a writer
and host of the aptly named larry elder
radio show Larry how's it goin on great
day thank you for having me I appreciate
it yeah thanks for coming in I've been
trying to make this happen with you for
a while darn tossing you forever
caught up with me you've been in this
studio before I have I've guest hosted
for Larry a couple times Larry King that
every King that's that's a Larry man yes
the thing is kinda for the full hour
yeah he can only have people with the
name Larry that's right I guess those
were two that work out for you so
there's a lot of stuff I want to talk
about and in the beginning of the show I
set up that I am a liberal you're a
conservative condolences by the time
this show is over we can move you to the
center a little bit and maybe by the
time the show's over we but that's what
it's all about that's why I've wanted to
have you on the show because I find
there were some people in the public
space that I disagree with but that I'd
like to sit down and talk about some of
the ideas and I consider you in that in
those days but before we get to the
politics
I like the audience to know a little bit
about the history of the people I'm
talking about so can you just I know you
were born in LA give me a little larry
elder history born and raised in l.a my
dad was a janitor he cleaned toilets my
dad was born in Athens Georgia doesn't
know who the mother is doesn't know what
those father is rather my name elder was
the name of some dude who was in his
life the longest my father was kicked
out of his house he was 13 years old by
his irresponsible grandmother and was on
his own from that point on my mom grew
up on a farm kind of aristocracy for a
black woman she owned the farm they
owned the farm anyway my dad and my mom
got together and moved to California in
the 40s I have two brothers I am as you
mentioned the lawyer born and raised in
LA and went to college in the East Coast
law school in the Midwest stayed in Ohio
for about 17 years came back to LA about
22 years ago got into TV and radio and
I've been doing it ever since
there you go all right so now we got we
got the meet what do you do now you're
not a practicing lawyer right negative
no yeah I did it for two and a half
three years and that was it I find a lot
of people in the public space either
were lawyers at one time
there's a ton of comedians that were
lawyers what is about lawyers a lot of
them want to get out what's that I'm not
sure that's true it's just a real
flexible thing to do you learn how to
reason you learn about the law you learn
about the Constitution if you're a trial
lawyer you learn how to think on your
feet and it lends itself to doing other
things but most people I know who went
to law school at least the ones I went
to law school with stayed in the law
yeah so is that a perfect segue to get
you to be someone that talks for a
living right like instead of having to
litigate it in the courtroom you could
litigate it on air and bounce back and
forth with people and that's right
although most lawyers are not trial
lawyers it's kind of the image of most
lawyers is that they're glib and fast
most lawyers sit behind a desk and fill
out papers they're their tax lawyers or
our constitutional lawyers or contract
lawyers or something like that only
about 10% of lawyers end up going to
becoming litigators and even a smaller
number of those actually try cases yeah
all right so now let's talk about
conservatism hmm let's do it so I've
mostly been calling out the left on my
show because I consider myself part of
the left right and I've seen the left
sort of really go off the deep end to
the left and I have been happy about it
so I haven't talked that much about the
right I've had a couple people on the
right so first off how would you define
conservatism what do you think that even
means at this point in America in 2016
what is it considered well I don't mind
being called a conservative answer if I
don't consider to be a four-letter word
but I really call myself a libertarian I
believe in article 1 section 8 of the
Constitution which gives the federal
government a small number of things to
do Dave meant money put together an army
deal with the border is a handful of
other things that's it
welfare healthcare abortion same-sex
marriage doctor sister suicide all the
social issues that the Supreme Court
takes up in my view they shouldn't take
up in the first place that should be
happened done on the state-by-state
basis that's what I think most
conservatives believe as well so I'm
with you on a lot of it and I definitely
have some libertarian beliefs myself I
think most people are libertarian they
just don't know it the founding fathers
were libertarians the family's father
has drafted a document that said our
rights come from a power other than
individuals and government doesn't give
us our rights we give government our
rights and power and everything else
should be left to the states and the
individual so that's
how the Constitution would start it
that's how the country was started and I
think that's how most Americans really
feel when they really think about it
well that's one of the funny things to
me and why I've defended somebody like
Rand Paul who's a lot of people would
say as a liberal I shouldn't be
defending he's a libertarian but he's a
libertarian so on issues such as
legalizing marijuana or gay marriage a
libertarian because you don't want the
government in your bedroom you shouldn't
care about threats issues and as a
liberal I want people to do what they
want and marry who they want so that's
somewhere where a libertarian and the
liberal can really sort of join together
right I think so however you have people
like Bill Maher running around calling
himself a libertarian Bill Maher is not
a libertarian he believes in higher
taxes he believes in a minimum wage
he supported Ralph Nader for for
government who wants to take over
businesses and have government run them
so a lot of people use it because it's a
sexy kind of term and have no idea what
it is right so that's the the economic
side of it so you you're sort of he's
liberal on the on the social stuff and
in a way as a conservative you're
actually pretty liberal on the
conservative on the social stuff again I
believe that same-sex marriage doctor
assisted suicide all these kinds of
things abortion should be done in a
state-by-state basis in California we
had two opportunities to vote for or
against same-sex marriage proposition 30
and another time when we voted on I
think was called issue 8 a measure 8 and
in both cases I voted in favor of
same-sex marriage in both cases I was
overruled I have no problem with the
idea that the majority of my fellow
Americans or fellow Californians did not
agree with me I don't believe that I
then go to the Supreme Court and cram it
down the throats of the other states
right ok so then that's that's the
states rights issue and sort of so you
would say that the Supreme Court is
legislating from the bench or something
to that effect yeah I would yeah and
that so so you're basically ok with what
happened you just don't like how it had
kept yeah so someone like Rand Paul
because it sounds like you have a lot
are you supporting ah no I'm not I don't
know I don't like Rand Paul because of
his position on Foreign Affairs and
defense a lot of libertarians and I
don't think being a libertarian leads
you to being an isolationist although
most libertarians are reasons that I
think are kind of confuse
but Rand Paul is one of those guys who
attacked George W Bush for the Iraq war
I think we were justified in going there
I think that the reason for going there
were legitimate and I think a lot of
liberals are hypocritical on this issue
too you talked about how you you
chastise people on the left for being
hypocrites I'll give you one big one the
argument against the Iraq war is that
George W Bush foolishly wanted to impose
our values on another another culture
had no idea what the aftermath would be
if we get rid of this bad guy right
however Obama comes into office he joins
with the British and the French and
bombing Libya getting rid of Qaddafi why
did he threaten us no they did so for
humanitarian civil rights reasons
Hillary recently had a debate was asked
about why she did that she said well
they so they could have free elections
where was the left a same thing with
regard to out to Egypt we get rid of
Mubarak he was a thug but they're all
thugs the brother Muslim Brotherhood
comes in there and Obama backs them and
and the country's worse than it was
before same thing and then a Senate now
backing the guy that took over right the
moment in Assad for reasons that escaped
me Obama decided a saw it had to go yeah
why these these countries did not
threaten us the way in my opinion Iraq
did Iraq was a deal after the after 9/11
ninety percent of the American people
believe that we're going to get hit
again and this guy was was stealing from
the oil for food program he was he was
interfering with our patrolling the
southern in no-fly zones he had used
chemical weapons on his own people we
know that because they used him on the
Iranians he used them on the Kurds he
tried to assassinate George Herbert
Walker Bush he was a threat and like it
or not at least we had a legitimate
reason for going there and he got the
backing of both the House and and the
Senate Obama did did did Egypt and he
did Libya and he did a Syria without the
backing of Congress and yet the left
didn't say a damn thing right sue
Perkins yeah so I'm with you on the
hypocrite mark because I listen I was
there's plenty of video I was against
the Libya thing because at the very
least at the very very least if we're
gonna have a military action we should
have congressional approval right so
then instead of calling it a war they
called it a kinetic military action well
and beyond that Libya did
pose a threat to us he had no WMD
because he gave them up after we went
into the war in Iraq he was scared bleep
'less he gave up the WMD not the United
Nations he gave it to us if they're
under lock and key in Tennessee as we
speak
so what was the rationale and where was
the left the same people yelling and
screaming about George W Bush and Dick
Cheney and neo-cons
and and nation-building where were they
they didn't say anything it's
hypocritical yeah well listen we don't
have congressional authorization right
now so I would assume by a lot of
standards on the left Obama is probably
a neocon to them right if they were if
they were being consistent but they're
not so but what was the actual threat I
mean so I'm with you on some of this in
terms of that we all sort of pick our
sides and then our values suddenly
change depending on who's in power but
what do you think your principles you
don't do that and I write myself to be
principled I I consider myself to be
principled as well so everything that
I've said in the past related it's all
the stuff still still sands up but what
was the actual threat from Iraq look I
know that that Saddam did horrible
things and you've laid out a couple of
them but what was the actual threat
george w bush properly said that they
were a grave and gathering danger after
9/11 ninety percent of the american
people who thought we were gonna get hit
again and thought the hit was gonna be
bigger than 9/11 so george w bush looks
around and says where are the threats we
were still technically at war against
saddam hussein we went to war against
him in 1991 and he promised to fully and
thoroughly declare his chemical and
biological weapons he failed to do so he
violated resolution after resolution
after resolution and we feared that he
would either use him himself or give
them to a terrorist and use them against
us and make 9/11 look like a picnic that
was a threat we gave him 15 months to
turn over this stuff and he refused to
do it
Bush went to the night that it did turn
out that there were no nuclear weapons
of mass describe actually I disagree
with that as well I believe the weapons
were there we gave him 15 months to
thoroughly declare what he did in that
15 months in my opinion he got rid of it
and I'm not the only person that said
that Dave the the National Intelligence
director our top spy his name is James
clapper he's in office right now under
Obama has publicly said he believes that
Saddam was saying did in fact have
stockpiles of WMD got rid of them in the
during the 15-month run-up to the war
the Israeli Mossad feels the same way
and there's
other American officials that have said
that so I don't believe George W Bush
got the intelligence wrong we have
sixteen intelligence agencies all 16
said at the highest level of probability
that Saddam Hussein has stockpiles of
chemical and biological weapons Obama
had the same CIA director who served
under Bill Clinton George Tenet
he said the likelihood that Saddam
Hussein had chemical weapons and
biological weapons was a slam dunk and
the same people that called George W
Bush a [ __ ] won him wanted him to go so
all 16 you guys say that he's got this
stuff and you save got it George I just
not feeling it so I'm not gonna do it
but he's a [ __ ]
so when you say that this is one of the
cases that part of the problem and I
think this is a through line through
everything we're gonna discuss for the
next hour is that I don't know who to
believe anymore that's become a thing so
James clapper he just met right he's the
same guy the same CIA director who sat
in front of Congress and said that we're
not spying on Americans remember and he
was scratching the top of his head
because as they say in Seinfeld when
you're lying and you touch the higher up
you touch on your face the bigger the
lie is right any strand he says we're
not wittingly spying on the American
public we now know that that was what he
said well I gave the least untruthful
answer I could give but later on he
admitted it and so to me as far as I'm
concerned he's legitimately honest guy
well I guess he gave the least honest
answer he's least untruthful and least
untruthful right but it wasn't that
guess I guess but it wasn't truthful
well it was classified yeah it was
classified he wasn't opposed to talk
about it alright so without without
getting too caught up in the words
though but do you think that's part of
the problem that we just don't know who
to believe anymore no I believe our
government officials we barely believe
the media well I have my own issues with
government but it might think my problem
with the Iraq war is that Republicans
failed to say what I've said and
defended even Jeb Bush has not defended
it properly he was asked when he first
started running what do you think about
the Iraq war well I I mean honestly if
you can't even defend what your brother
did how can other people do it so I
think Americans have forgotten why we
went there at one time 73% of the
American people supported this war you
have to remind people of why you why
you've gone to war might be what the
reasons are and people have forgotten
and now they have this vague idea that
George W Bush overreacted and went in
there and deposed somebody because he
just didn't like him and that's why we
were there and let's not do that anymore
that's kind of how people have given the
cliffnotes version of what happened and
it's unfair so what would you say to the
people that would argue that Isis it
wouldn't exist right now if we hadn't
toppled Saddam because he at least had
for all the horrible things he was doing
in the bath party we're doing terrible
things and they were executing people
and throwing days off roofs and you know
using mustard gas on the Kurds and all
that stuff but at least he was keeping a
sort of lid on the actual craziness that
we're seeing right now my my problem
with that is that we don't know what's
that I'm just saying would have done had
we not gone there even though we didn't
find the stockpiles there were two
people that george w bush sent to find
the stockpiles one was named david kaye
the other was named chuck dopher both of
them said we didn't find any stockpiles
we screwed up however this guy was going
to reconstitute his WMD program and
reconstitute his nuclear program when
the heat was off so we would've had to
deal with him anyway the second thing I
say is that President Obama pulled out
all the truth because he ran in 2008 and
said the Iraq war was a dumb war we
never should have gone there over the
advice of Hillary his Secretary of State
over the advice of his then Secretary of
Defense Leon Panetta over the advice of
his former Secretary of Defense Robert
Gates over the advice of the Joint
Chiefs he pulled out all the troops he
was warned if you do this there'll be a
vacuum he did it anyway Ray Odierno is a
member of the Joint Chiefs he just
retired and he gave us speech when he
retired and he was asked if he does he
believed that we should have left people
there he said yes had we done so Isis
could have been dealt with so in my
opinion however you feel about it
when Obama walked in and heritage this
mess yeah he should have made it better
it not worse he made it worse so in a
way you're so you're sort of blaming
both sides right in that in that or I
guess I would blame both side I don't
put words in your mouth I would blame
both sides here and that we went to the
wrong war and then by Obama leaving the
way he did even though most of the
Americans very clearly didn't want to be
there anymore and when he ran for
president seven years ago that his whole
thing was we're gonna get out as soon as
possible but that then created the the
breeding ground for this because we
didn't leave in a in a sword I'll go
half way with you yeah we didn't go into
the wrong war went to the right war for
the right reasons
I think the intelligence was good and I
think the problem was when Obama came in
he wanted to get out so quick
he did not realize what the aftermath
would be and I'm not the only one who
said this Robert glazier has written a
book scathing attack the most scathing
attack on a sitting commander-in-chief
by a former member of cabinet member I
have ever read and he even recently a
few days ago Dave said that Obama's
national security and foreign policy
advisers are dangerously naive they see
the world through this prism that they
want which is why the Benghazi thing
happened the reason the magazi thing
happened is Obama's running in 2012 GM
is dead GM is alive Osama bin Laden is
dead and al Qaeda is on the run
therefore Benghazi was not thoroughly
defended because they thought that the
Libyans were happy with us because we
got rid of Gaddafi yeah and so they in
my opinion the Obama administration sees
the world through their a prism of this
ridiculous idea that if we are nicer to
people and reach out with an unclench
fist they will reach out in kind the
world doesn't work that way we have bad
people who hate us and we need to deal
with it right so I'm with you on that
part for sure because look if you think
back the big speech that Obama gave in
Cairo which was that everyone said this
is the reset this is that we're gonna be
different and we're gonna try to deal
with people and that's with bombs more
with discussion I mean the Middle East
especially but most of the world we were
more in more of a precarious place now
then I don't think any part of the world
is better off with Obama in and I think
that you look at polls now george w bush
left office in the in the low-30s I
don't think any president has been that
unpopular in my lifetime you look at
polls now more people like George W Bush
didn't like Obama Obama's rating is at
45% Bill Clinton's at this juncture in
the seventh year of his term he was at
65% most American believer on the wrong
track economically and most Americans
believe are on the wrong track in terms
of foreign policy yeah all right so I
don't want to get too lost in just
foreign policy so last thing on this is
a lot of what you're saying sort of
sounds like neoconservative stuff to me
is there can you be a libertarian and a
neoconservative I mean I know this is
what you're getting for it this is sort
of why you don't like Rand Paul but do
those things seem like they have nothing
to do with each other and yet I know
that there's a lot of people that do
sort of get what your what you're saying
well the term neoconservatism to me is a
four-letter word is a term that people
invent too
to malign somebody's position I see the
world realistically I think we have
enemies we need to deal with them I did
not believe as you did just now pointed
out that we should have gone to war in
in Libya I don't believe in doing
anything unless this is consistent with
our national security interests when
Jimmy Carter for example through the
Shah of Iran under the bus in the 70s
what was that all about he did it
because he wanted freedom he wanted to
liberate the people who are behind bars
and the same people we now call
terrorists these are the ones that Obama
forced the Shah to let out of prison and
they ultimately topple the regime what's
that all about it's not our job to
impose democracy it's our job to make
sure that countries are are not our
enemies our countries are doing things
that are consistent with our own
national security interests and that and
that's my problem right so you don't
want a nation build you want to do
things that you consider sort of
defensive posture correct we went into
Haiti I think during Bill Clinton's
administration because they were having
difficulty it's not our job